north korea is stepping up its challenge
to the u.s in asia american officials
say kim jong-un's regime has been
test-firing components of a new
intercontinental ballistic missile the
country has ramped up its missile
testing since the beginning of the year
elizabeth palmer has more
north korea had said the launches two in
the past two weeks were to help develop
satellites but u.s intelligence believes
they were really to test components for
a much larger weapon the gigantic
hwasong-17 rolled out in a military
parade back in 2020 but as far as anyone
knows never actually fired
it's an intercontinental ballistic
missile and if it works designed to
reach anywhere in the continental united
states
north korea's leader kim jong-un today
appeared at a space launch pad and
announced he's also going to speed up
the development of military satellites
negotiations between kim jong-un and
former president trump in 2018 and 19
collapsed with no deal to curb north
korea's weapons program
the biden administration has said it is
willing to meet with north korea any
time but hasn't offered a concrete
proposal to get talks underway
meanwhile in just the first 10 weeks of
this year western analysts think that
north korea has manufactured enough
nuclear material for one or even two
more atomic bombs nate
elizabeth thank you